hey this is presh talwalkar
find the value of the following series
the first term is 1 divided by the
quantity 10 to the power of negative 9
plus 1
the second term is 1 divided by the
quantity 10 to the negative eight plus
one
and this continues until the last two
terms
of one divided by ten to the power of
eight plus one
plus one divided by ten to the power of
nine plus one
i thank gusty from indonesia for the
suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
when i tried to solve the problem at
first i was stumped
so i went to my bag of tricks i tried to
see all of the common ways to solve a
series
i first checked if it was an arithmetic
series
it was not
then i tried to see if it was a
geometric series again it was not
it wasn't a telescoping series and i
couldn't recognize it as a power series
then i noticed a little bit of a pattern
there's a symmetry in this sum
this is the trick that helped me solve
the problem
i noticed the first and the last terms
paired off
then the second term and the second to
last term paired off and so on
so let's see how this simplifies
define a k
as equal to 1 divided by 10 to the power
of k plus 1.
let's now try and evaluate the sum in
the following fashion the first term is
a of negative nine the second term is a
of negative eight
then in the middle we have a zero and
the last two terms are a8 and a9
so what we will do is we will pair off
a negative k with a k
let's try and simplify this sum
a negative k is equal to 1 divided by 10
to the power of negative k plus 1
and a k is equal to 1 divided by the
quantity 10 to the power of k plus 1.
so how can we simplify this
first we want a common denominator
we'll take the denominator of the second
fraction and multiply that term in the
numerator and denominator of the first
fraction
we also take the denominator of the
first fraction and multiply that
quantity in the numerator and
denominator of the second fraction
we can thus add the numerators of these
two fractions
from here we'll simplify the denominator
in the numerator we can group the one
and one terms together so we get two
in the denominator we'll multiply these
two binomials we get 10 to the power of
k plus 10 to the power of negative k
plus 10 to the power of k minus k plus
1.
10 to the power of k minus k is equal to
10 to the power of 0 and that's equal to
1.
so then the denominator will have 1 plus
1 which is equal to 2. so notice now the
numerator and the denominator are
exactly equal to each other so they'll
cancel out to be equal to one
thus
a negative k
plus a k is equal to one
wow
so now let's solve the problem
we'll pair off the first and last terms
that'll be equal to one
then we'll pair off the second and the
second to last term
that will be equal to one
and we'll have exactly nine of these
pairs
so this will be equal to nine plus a
zero
we then substitute for a zero
then ten to the power of zero is equal
to one
one divided by one plus one is equal to
one half
so this sum is equal to nine plus one
half which is equal to nine point five
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]
you